devastación en gerson deja un ataque con
misiles a edificios residenciales
la situación es ahora más miedosas y la
comparamos con la semana anterior Porque
ahora mismo los ataques están siendo muy
fuertes mucha gente se ha ido porque
temen por sus vidas
por sus pertenencias y por sus niños
todos están yendo hasta el lugar llegó
el gobernador de la región de los lab
llanushevish
mientras caminaba por el lugar y hablaba
con los residentes los bombardeos
continuaron pese a la salida de las
tropas rusas y la retoma de partes de la
región por parte de Ucrania las tropas
ucranianas advierten que gerson se
enfrentará a una intensificación de los
ataques a medida que los rusos se
atrincheran al lado del Río nieper La
población de la ciudad se ha reducido de
300.000 a 80.000 habitantes tras nueve
meses de guerra cuando los rusos se
retiraron destruyeron parte de la
infraestructura por lo que la gente se
enfrenta a la escasez de agua y
electricidad mientras el kremlin ataca
centrales energéticas que han dejado
sumidos en la oscuridad y a merced del
frío a millones de habitantes según el
presidente celensky
watch
a partir de esta tarde los apagones
continúan en la mayoría de las regiones
y en kiev en total más de 6 millones de
abonados el miércoles por la noche Se
desconectaron casi 12 millones la
mayoría de los problemas se dan
actualmente en la capital así como en la
región de kiev Odessa
y la región de Nitro
también
están allí dicen que a pesar de todo no
quieren ser evacuados ya que no tienen a
dónde ir